let's try to calculate thirty-nine point
one minus zero point seven nine four and
so pause the video and try this on your
own
alright I'm assuming you've given a go
at it so now let's work through it
together so I'm going to rewrite this
it's thirty nine point one - I'm going
to line up the decimals so that I have
the right place values below the right
place values - the zero is in the ones
place so I'll put it in the ones place
zero point seven nine four and now we're
ready to subtract now how do we subtract
four from nothingness here nine from
nothingness here well the same thing is
nothing the same thing as nothing is a
zero and so now we can start to think
about how to subtract well we still have
the problem well we're trying to
subtract four from zero so trying to
subtract nine from zero so what we could
do is take this 1/10 and try to regroup
it into the hundreds place and the
thousands place so let's think about
this if we make this if we make actually
that's not actually going to solve our
problem well we could do it but then
we're going to have zero tenths and
we're still going to have a problem here
so actually let me go to the ones place
so let me get rid of a ones so that's
eight ones which is going to be ten
tenths so that's going to now we're
going to have eleven tenths the ten tens
from here plus one is eleven tenths now
let's take one of those tenths so that
we have ten tenths and give it to the
hundredths so that's going to be ten
hundredths and now let's take one of
those hundredths so now we have nine
hundredths and give it to the
thousandths so that's going to be ten
thousandths now we're ready to subtract
so ten let me do this in yellow 10 minus
4 is 6 9 minus 9 is 0 10 minus 7 is 3 we
have our decimal point 8 minus 0 is 8
and then we have 3 minus nothing is 3 so
we're done thirty eight point three zero
six